bonsoir à tous et à toutes aujourd'hui
la paix de notre pays a été rompu par un
acte de haine et de brutalité un acte de
lâcheté qui ciblait le coeur même de
notre démocratie
le coeur de ce qui nous définit en tant
que peuple je me tiens ce soir aux côtés
de mes collègues de notre premier
ministre et de tous les canadiens
l'attak que nous avons subies a été
d'une violence soudaine et fatale elle a
frappé l'enceinte même où nous débattons
de nos idées tout en sachant bien que
peu importe nos différences les
problèmes seront toujours résolu de
manière pacifique
cette attaque avait pour objectif de
saper notre confiance et de nous diviser
en utilisant la peur cette tentative a
échoué au contraire les événements
d'aujourd'hui nous ont rapprochés
ils nous ont rendu encore plus fort et
plus résolue
j'aimerais saluer les braves hommes et
femmes de nos corps policiers des
services de sécurité et de nos forces
canadiennes la détermination le
professionnalisme et l'héroïsme dont
vous avez fait preuve aujourd'hui et
j'en ai été témoin moi-même resteront
ancrées dans notre mémoire
bien que nous ayons été témoin d' acte
horrible
nous avons aussi eu la chance de voir
votre courage à l'oeuvre vous avez
incarné la force
la vaillance et les valeurs de tout le
canada
nos pensées et nos prières accompagnent
la famille et les proches du caporal
n'est fait ciré lô le soldat des forces
canadiennes d'amandine 90 herriot qui a
perdu la vie ce matin le deuxième en
seulement quelques jours
le caporal serré l'eau montait la garde
devant un monument dédié
au sacrifice de ceux qui l'ont précédé à
sa famille et à ses proches
je tiens à rappeler que 35 millions de
canadiens au pays et à l'étranger
pleure avec vous ce soir et nous
n'oublierons pas en de tels moments
malgré le désarroi les canadiens se
serre les coudes et s'unissent dans le
deuil
le canada a été ébranlée aujourd'hui
mais nous n'allons pas vacillé
nous nous sommes levés ce matin dans un
pays d'amour de diversité et 2 et et ça
serait paraît demain matin ses actes et
est alimentée par la haine et avait pour
but de semer la haine en nous cela ne
marcherait pas nous resterons debout
solidaires les uns des eaux
nous allons continuer à protéger la
démocratie et nous allons l'emporter
contre ceux qui propage la peur
bonne soirée